vous savez dans la vie quand on veut
aller au bout de nos idées
quand on veut s'assurer que
en plus faire partie de la solution
lorsque l'on voit
montréal
péricliter
lorsqu'on voit des hommes et des femmes
qui souffrent qui sont laissés pour
compte quand on voit la situation
qui est nette en matière de sécurité et
que on a perdu ce sens de métropole où
on devenait on ne venait plus
incontournable dans quelques dément que
ce soit c'est pas par rapport à ce qu'on
fait au premier mandat ou aujourd'hui
c'est lorsque nous avons cette fonction
de maire nous devons continuellement
être à l'affût et ou de vin et lorsque
je parlais qu'il faut que montréal
arrêté dans la salle data j'espère que
ça va être le cas pour les quatre
prochaines années je veux évidemment
saluée et avoir une pensée pour les
candidats et les candidates
le don de soi choisir de se présenter
franchir ce rubicon qui fait en sorte
qu'on dit je veux faire partie de la
solution peu importe le parti politique
mérite toutes nos félicitations et
j'aimerais qu'on leur fasse une bonne
note
je connais citer tous ceux et celles qui
ont été élus en politique des gagnants
et des perdants mais je demande il ya
beaucoup de gens qui se sont présentés
pour la première fois dans notre équipe
et je sais que la défaite peut faire mal
moi c'était ma douzième campagne
électorale on en a vu de toutes les
couleurs je pense donc je reçois un
appel en plus un bon ben
[Musique]
oui c'est de la musique de bilbao que
j'aime désolé
continuer
je suis un peu déçu je dois vous avouer
du taux très très faible du taux de
participation
la démocratie municipale mérite qu'on la
protège mérite que l'on puisse s'assurer
qu'elle demeure
du problème du vote postal pour les 70
ans et plus il ya une réalité chez nos
jeunes je pense qui est essentiel est
important que tous ceux et celles qui
sont dans la chose publique puisse
assurer qu'ils aient une plus grande
participation pour les prochaines
élections quelle qu'elle soit c'est pas
juste au niveau de montréal c'est dans
le milieu municipal je vous ai toujours
dit que dans les 20 prochaines années
plus de 70% de la population va se
retrouver dans les villes il est
primordial que l'on puisse prendre notre
place comme gouvernement de proximité et
être un gouvernement de proximité
demande qu'on puisse démontrer cette
force de frappe que constitue notre
population et ça se fait par les
élections
je veux remercier francesco meli comme
directeur de campagne qui fait un
travail exceptionnel
merci contre le sco merci à toute
l'équipe
merci à tous ceux et celles j'ai vu des
centaines et des centaines de bénévoles
j'ai vu des candidats jusqu'à la fin
avec leurs bénévoles qui ont travaillé
d'arrache-pied et qui voyait comment
montréal pouvait devenir beau un bel
avec nos avec notre notre point de vue
je demande qu'on mette la hargne de côté
il faut qu'une administration quelle
qu'elle soit ne soit pas là pour ses
militants mais sois là pour tous les
montréalais et toutes les montréalaises
montréal en vaut la chandelle j'aime
montréal d'amour montréal a besoin
d'amour montréal a besoin d'elle et tous
ceux et celles qui se sont fait élire
doivent faire partie de la solution
alors j'ai un jeu je demande à tous les
gens dansent en montréal évidemment ils
vont jouer leur rôle au niveau de
l'opposition même moment donné faut
transcender les partis politiques faut
arrêter continuellement de pointer du
doigt ce fut une des campagnes les plus
sales que j'ai vécu mais quand on
travaille au niveau des idées faut
passer par dessus et montréal vaut la
peine d'être vécue on a parlé de
sécurité on a parlé d'habitation on a
parlé de tout ce qui touche les la
livraison des services
s'est pas toujours des belles choses à
voir la question de la propreté la
question des services de proximité et
surtout la gestion des fonds publics
j'aime pas ce que je vois présentement
sur le plan budgétaire et ce qui est
clair c'est que si nous sommes dans
l'ensemble pas des partis politiques qui
prennent en compte la ou dans un conseil
municipal nous sommes une administration
et notre rôle c'est de s'assurer que
l'on puisse démontrer que toujours des
choses à améliorer
il faut arrêter d'être dogmatique à
outrance il faut qu'on soit pragmatique
et c'est ce que j'aime est dans sa
moyenne
j'ai vu des hommes et des femmes
exceptionnelles j'ai vu des hommes et
des femmes grandir j'ai vu des gens se
donner pour faire en sorte que montréal
puisse retrouver
sa force de frappe cette campagne
électorale s'il ya un point positif
c'est que non seulement du sang nouveau
non seulement il ya un bon mix
d'expérience on a eu l'occasion de
mettre de l'avant un programme
exceptionnel je veux encore une fois
remercier emilia guillon mais tous ceux
et celles qui ont participé
c'est pas ça pas été fait cinq points de
table cela c'est un travail de tout
instant qui a été fait pour le fruit
d'expériences de compétences et
d'assurance parce que là on est encore
dans la pandémie les gens sont écoeurés
constate sur la gueule des gens sont
écoeurés construit des noms on a besoin
d'un plan d'action on a besoin aussi
d'être beaucoup plus rassembleur et
d'arrêter que bon le secteur privé si si
les développeurs c'est ça qu'on arrête
de mettre un contre l'autre qu'on arrête
de dire continuellement c1 contre les
autres on est capable on est plus fort
que ça le vivre ensemble c'est pas
seulement une vue de l'esprit le vivre
ensemble c'est un concept intrinsèque
qui nous définissent et l'adn de
montréal il ya des gens de différentes
communautés qui se sentent délaissés il
ya des gens de différentes communautés
qui pensent qu'ils font l'objet
d'intolérance de profilage de racisme
système et notre quelle qu'elle soit et
de s'assurer qu'on travaille va être cet
équilibre entre l'ouverture et la
vigilance et il faut arrêter de se
mettre la tête dans sa il ya un problème
de sécurité à montréal et tous et toutes
nous devons travailler pour assurer que
l'on combat ce sentiment d'insécurité
just a few words quelques mots en
anglais
j'aimerais féliciter
pour sa campagne
la gauche anchois ont laissé certaines
choses
deux côtés mais le coeur y était
j'aimerais féliciter tous ces candidats
qui se sont présentés sous sa bannière
je pense que la communauté anglophone se
sent un peu esseulé il faut ramener les
gens il faut
ramener secteur de fonds et s'assurer
que les liens soient leurs et qu' on ne
fait pas toujours maître de l'a20 le
concept des deux seules études et faire
rejaillir la lumière sur cette ville
mais le résultat est clair on en gagne
en imper vous savez mais je suis
vraiment content que j'avançais des
idées j'étais je suis très content que
quoi qu'il arrive tout l'exécutent âge
qu'on va essayer que moi je me
concentrais sur les haies des jeux
polarisé mon attention sur les gens cas
j'adore les montréalais et montréalaises
et notre hub bellevue et c'est ça qui
est le plus important pour rassembler
les gens
certains seront cynique avec cette
élection ou à cause du taux de
participation des gens vont là passé par
toute la gamme des émotions
je vous invite tous et toutes à
continuer continuer par cette voie
citoyenne soit au niveau de ce que vous
faites dans vos arrondissement on a
besoin d'une meilleure concertation au
niveau des arrondissements il ya
plusieurs dossiers importants qui ne
touchaient peut-être pas l'ensemble de
la métropole mais qui était nécessaire
pour qu'on puisse travailler dans leur
milieu dans leur localité et il faut
arrêter de penser que montréal c'est
juste le central il faudra regarder la
périphérie les des laissés pour compte à
cause sur le plan géographique également
donc travaillons tous et toutes pour
nous assurer qu'on puisse travailler
pour le bien commun chers amis ça a été
un plaisir de faire cette campagne avec
vous je suis je suis très très fier de
vous dans la vie c'est mieux d'avoir des
regrets que des rats morts je n'ai ni
regrets ni remords et quand on a
l'impression de d'aller au bout de ses
idées moi j'ai j'ai vécu ma propre
résilience je me suis relevé et j'avais
j'avais le goût à la suite de ce que je
voyais d'offrir à la population une
alternative valable pour qu'on puisse
ensemble retrouver cela la magie de
montréal j'espère que tous et toutes ou
pensez que j'ai pu y avoir contribué je
veux vous souhaiter une excellente
soirée je veux vous dire avant tout que
je vous aime et que vous avez une place
extraordinaire dans mon coeur merci
beaucoup